[Music]
a year into the pandemic medical experts
are worried about the potential
long-term health effects of miscancer
screenings
hundreds of thousands of cancer
screenings and tests were delayed
with facilities closed amid concerns
about the coronavirus and now the
experts fear
this could delay critical diagnoses
maria villareal introduces us to two
women who experience
just that be gentle
okay shaving her head was cathartic for
rhonda johnstone of roswell new mexico
it was actually really special johnstone
is 52 and battling cancer she has a mass
of tumors in her right breast
when you got the news what was the first
thing that ran through your mind
fear i've got five little grandkids
and i want to be here to watch them grow
up
but after she discovered the first lump
six long months passed before she was
finally diagnosed
what has been the hardest part for you
i've really had to fight
i've had to fight for testing i've had
to fight to be seen i've just had to
fight for answers and i don't think
that's fair johnstone is just one
of hundreds of thousands whose cancer
screenings were deferred when the
pandemic shut down clinics and labs
i'm seeing people with advanced cancers
dr linda ann smith is a breast surgeon
in albuquerque
she's now treating johnstone half a year
later
there were no words for how striking
that picture was how big the tumor was
it was everywhere it was all four
quadrants it was underneath the nipple
johnstone is getting chemotherapy to
shrink the tumors
so smith can operate mammogram saved
your life
surgery has become increasingly common
during the pandemic
we're doing harder surgeries sicker
patients people who've had to go through
extensive
treatment before we can take them to
surgery for 59 year old yvette lowry of
rock hill south carolina
that meant chemotherapy
her annual mammogram was canceled during
the early outbreak of covett and the
backlog of screenings
made it hard to reschedule in august
lowry felt
two lumps under her arm after three
months of delayed screenings and tests
she finally got her diagnosis stage
three breast cancer
it's been a little emotional
but i just keep my faith and trust in
god
if her cancer had been detected last may
or june doctors believe
they may have been able to prevent the
spread last week lowery had
a double mastectomy they put our life
on a standstill what was the hardest
part for you
the hardest part was telling my kids
i didn't want them to worry
i didn't want to be crying experts
predict the number of people who will
die from breast or colorectal cancer in
the u.s
will increase by nearly 10 000 over the
next decade because of covid19's impact
on cancer care at some point
dr karen finkelstein who treats
gynecologic cancers
has seen a 30 percent decline in cancer
referrals
i'm being paralyzed i've been frozen by
kovid because
it's made it's changed the landscape of
of medicine and patients
last year has taken a toll on her
personally you start to
feel a sense of despair the hurdles
kovid has
forced us to face this year some of them
have been insurmountable i love you it's
that love from john stone's family and
for her family that gives her the
strength to keep fighting
it doesn't seem like you're going to
take this sitting down are you
no i'm not i'm going to get it
i'm going to get it good for cbs this
morning
medela villarreal dallas
we want her to get it good too our dr
david agus who specializes in treating
patients with advanced cancers
joins us now good morning to you david
this is such a great wake-up call to
those of us who have put off screenings
for whatever reason
so here's a question what screening
should we absolutely not put off or
delay
well you know during cover there was
almost a 50 drop in the diagnosis of
breast cancer week by week and so
those breast cancers are still there
they're going to be diagnosed so you
need to get your mammogram
you need to get a psa test if you're man
a lung screening test if you're a smoker
colonoscopy all the standard screening
tests and you need to go to your doctor
to get that standard blood test
other things are found in the blood test
hospitals have remarkable programs now
to prevent and most doctors are actually
and
nurses are vaccinated so it is very low
risk to go
get the screening you know and then some
vaccinated
people are reporting swollen lymph nodes
underneath their armpits which can
sometimes be mistaken
as a sign of breast cancer what do you
have to say about that
yeah gail i mean you're right is that
after the vaccination for six to eight
weeks lymphos get enlarged and that's
part of your
your immune response and they're
actually lymph nodes in the breast so
you can get false positives if you have
a mammogram
or other medical test during that time
period so if you can if they're elective
if they're part of your routine
screening
delay at six to eight weeks after the
vaccine
can i talk about the astrazeneca the
latest thing that we're hearing there
that now they're saying the efficacy is
now 76
down from 79 percent it's very slight i
get it but should people be concerned it
seems every day there's something new
about astrazeneca are you worried
yeah i'm worried about the
communications group i mean this was a a
problem of omission they put the the
data they had in february
but february to march there were another
49 cases and the data went from 79
to 76 but the data in the elderly went
from 80 to 85 percent so these are small
changes
it is still an amazing vaccine and we
shouldn't let this noise
affect our acceptance of something that
could save our lives all right dr david
agus thank you so much
we'll be right back